Hello everybody.
Well, thank you. I really appreciate that. I, I've
got to actually start this talk with a, with a really short
story, a kind of a funny story, maybe get a kick out
of it. It just before I came out, they
said, well, hey, can you stand over to the side because we're gonna
introduce you, then we want you to walk out. And
I said, oh, I get to make like a big sort of a rock
star entry, right? Like I can come out.
And she said, yeah, we're gonna play
like Metallica, Enter Sandman as you're like
entering the stage. And I said, oh, that means I'm gonna put
him to sleep, right? You know, so,
like, anyway, I just thought that was really funny, I thought that
I would share that with you. So,
anyway, welcome to today's talk,
Driving resilience with assurance and visibility
from edge to cloud. And, uh, let me
just start by asking you guys a couple of questions
by a show of hands. So, how many of you
work, uh, in a more application-focused
setting like DevOps, SREs,
that type of thing?
Nobody? OK, that's a good start.
How many of you are more focused on the network side?
How many of you work, uh, work in network
operations or manage infrastructure,
uh, those types of things.
OK, so that's, so that's great. So, what
we're, what we're gonna actually talk about here today,
um, is, is assurance. Um,
and let me just kind of get started here,
um, by talking about some of the challenges
that we have in today's world. And And
today's world is, is way different than the
way things used to be. So there's a new normal
in place. And what we've seen really is,
is really three different departures. So there's been
a departure
from reactive troubleshooting
to an approach that's really centered
on AI ops and proactive,
um, incident detection and then proactive
remediation. And so that's
the, that's the mode or that's the posture that
we really need to be in today.
The second thing is basically
unified end to end visibility. So,
it used to be that, you know,
within your operational silos, this is why I asked the
question, uh, from a network standpoint, you were
used to using network tooling, like network management
or NPM types of tools.
If you worked in application design or
application architecture,
you used
application. Performance monitoring or full stack
observability, that type of thing. And
what, what the new normal really demands now
in your environments is something that's a lot more unified
and a lot more seamless for your end users.
And then finally, we're really talking about
a departure
from traditional operational
models to one that's much more
collaborative. And one that's really designed
to implement simplified and streamlined
workflows into your
operations so that you can achieve better collaboration,
so that you can reduce the amount of finger pointing that
you deal with on a day to day basis, and that
you can basically address your end users'
concerns and assure their experiences
in a much more proactive and
effective way.
And really what's driving a lot of this, um,
is the increased complexity that we
say, that we see across
the digital landscape in today's world.
And it really starts with your end users.
Your end users are now, they used to be that they were all
located in offices. Well, now they're working at
home, or, and they're working in
offices that can be, that can be in campus
locations. They can be located in coffee
shops, and maybe they're not even human. Maybe
they're IOT events. But,
but nonetheless,
these users are trying to gain. Access
to those applications, and those applications
are now no longer hosted in
enterprise or premises specific environments.
They're hosted in, in, in hybrid cloud environments.
They're hosted in in AWS EC2
instances. They leverage
services like global load balancers or CDNs.
They leverage cloud-based services like DNS,
but they still can be located in enterprise
data centers, or they can be SAS
applications, and SAS applications pose a significant
challenge
because you as an applications person or
some Supporting your end user community,
you don't have any visibility or control into SAS
environments.
But the real challenge lies in this midsection
here, which is the digital supply chain,
and that consists of your own private networks.
It consists of internet transit. It
consists of cloud provider networks and all the
adjacent services,
as well as all the underlying technologies
and dependencies
that make that work, like BGP, like the
internet routing system, like DNS and
things like that. So you Really need
to have complete end to end visibility
in order to attain the
proactive operational stance that
you really want to achieve here. So
now, the reality is that
most teams and most IT organizations
today operate in somewhat of a siloed
model, meaning that some of you
are responsible for applications, whether
you're DevOps, whether you're application
architects, whether you're developers,
whether you're SREs,
some, some, some of You are responsible
for managing or maintaining infrastructure,
and that can be your on-premise locations
or it can be your cloud environments. It could be that
you're an architect focused specifically
on Kubernetes, specifically on distributed
container-based applications, and so on,
that also has connectivity, or you
can be working in a network silo. And,
and in the network world, basically, you're really
concerned purely with the connectivity and the
performance and the availability
of your networks
across this entire digital supply chain.
But the problem is, is what do you do for those environments
that are outside of your control? Because again,
you don't control SAS applications, you
don't control ISP networks,
you, you, you have very little control even
over, over your cloud environments, and
you really,
uh, you don't have control, but you are still responsible
for delivering high-quality user
experiences to your end users.
And so you really don't have Control over
that. So,
the, and the problem now is that, is
that slow response time
and degraded performance leads to degraded
experiences.
When your users have a degraded experience,
they think that that's the same as an outage from
their perspective. Why?
Because it's stopping them from being productive. It's
preventing them from reaching your website. It's
preventing them from executing transactions.
or payments on your websites, you
know, and so if there's an, if there's a slowdown
or a bottleneck or some kind of degradation
across that digital delivery chain,
they see that as the same as an outage.
Whether it's a network issue, whether it's an
application issue, they don't really care.
But guess what? You do, OK. You
have to solve that issue
somehow, some way,
wherever it happens to reside.
And so what I'm going to talk about are a couple of different
solutions from Cisco,
one being Splunk observability,
and then the other being Cisco 1000 Eyes,
which is essentially assurance for digital
experiences.
And so what Cisco's actually done, and
we talked about some of the problems inherent in this
earlier,
which is that we've, we've gotten into this
sort of a siloed environment, right? So,
so typically Splunk is used,
you know, within application-centric environments.
Typically it's used by, by. Us folks,
by infrastructure
managers,
even by security teams because Splunk
really excels in security and all
those use cases, but it's, it's more of an
application and infrastructure-focused
solution. 1000 Eyes is
more of a, of a network-focused solution. We
are really
dedicated to assuring the connectivity
across the digital supply chain to
ensure that your users can reach
all those applications, no matter where
they are, no matter who owns. The, etc.
And so what we've done at Cisco is we've sort
of joined forces between these two
solutions, between Splunk observability
and 1000 eyes assurance, and we've basically
integrated those. And the reason we've done
that is to make it easier and more
seamless for you as an IT
organization to assure resilient
networks, resilient experiences, and
high quality end user experiences.
And so that's what we're going to show you today. And we've come
up with 3 different solutions that actually
show. and I'm going to demonstrate these in just a
couple of moments.
The first is the Cisco 1000 eyes app for
Splunk. And if you're familiar with Splunk, you know that
Splunk maintains a vast
store or a library of applications
that's really built on a system called Splunkbase.
And then Splunkbase is, what that is, is, is it really
Splunk has intelligence and tooling
that allows you to take the data that's collected
within Splunk and build custom applications.
And so what we've done is we've built a custom
application for Splunk.
Called the Cisco 1000 Eyes app
for Splunk, that's located in
Splunk Base, so you can download it and start using
it right away if you're a Splunk customer.
Um, and I'm gonna show you what that looks like.
Basically, what it does is it takes metrics
and data,
performance metrics, primarily network telemetry,
and exports it, uh, via API
and open telemetry, um, into the Splunk
dashboard.
The second solution that we have is
an integration between 1000 Eyes
and Splunk Observability Cloud.
So again, what we do is, is we export
our data into, uh,
uh Splunk's got something called the Common
Information Model or the CIM,
you know, where we basically map our telemetry
and map all those parameters into
their into the database so that you can
now, uh, display thousandized
telemetry within Splunk and vice versa.
So these, these are bi-directional integrations, meaning
if you're a Splunk customer, you can view 1000
eyes telemetry in Splunk.
If you're a 1000 eyes customer, you can
view. Splunk metrics,
events, traces,
logs
within 1000 eyes. And then finally, we have
something called Splunk ITSI
bidirectional integration.
IT service intelligence from Splunk
essentially is a machine learning. It's a, it's
really an AI ops tool that does automatic
preventative, uh, proactive correlation
of all the data that's collected within Splunk,
um, and then shows it in a dashboard. And
so, again, what we're doing is we're We're exporting
1000 Eyes network telemetry, uh,
into Splunk ITSI so that you can view
incidents there.
We've also got links from 1000 Eyes
directly into Splunk ITSI.
So if you identify an issue with an
application, you basically eliminated the network
as the culprit. You can then go
directly into Splunk ITSI and,
and see essentially a preventative or
recommendations for exactly how to
rectify that problem.
So let's go ahead and, uh, and show
these demos.
So this is actually the, this is the,
um, the T1 1000 Eyes application for Splunk.
This combines deep visibility with AI driven
insights. And what you're basically seeing here,
you're actually in Splunk right now,
um, but what, you're in Splunk Enterprise, and
you're seeing tests that 1000 Eyes have
run. And you can see
you've got network latency, you've got network loss,
network. Jitter, and we're actually, we
have the ability to display that by
application. So we can identify the application and we can
see here that there's some consistent
packet loss, some consistent latency
within the network.
So from there, we can link directly into 1000
Eyes, and this is a 1 1000 Eyes test
view where we can show that, that, that, that availability
dropped. We drop into a 1000
eyes path visualization.
And we can identify very, very quickly that there's
high latency on this, on this network
transit link, and there's also packet loss
happening in the network,
both at the intermediate node and also
at the node that's in the destination network.
And so, right away, we can see
from what we got in through the Spunk
application, jump from Splunk into 1000
eyes and quickly move to diagnose
and resolve the issue.
Now, this is actually
the second one. This is basically the ITSI
integration.
Um, actually, this is, yeah, this is actually, I'm
sorry, this is the Cisco 1000
integration with Spunk observability cloud.
And what this is starting is we're actually in the 1000I
platform, and on this particular test, we
see that server application availability
has dropped precipitously.
Now we can go into our connect phases.
We can see that DNS resolved. We've got
connection, we've got send and receive, but
we've got HTTP errors, meaning
the application, the page really can't load for that
end user, and they're Probably going to log a call
and complain about that.
So what we do from here is we actually
can bring up within
1000 eyes,
uh, a service map, and we can basically
see high latency across this
transit, and we can see
a lot of, a lot of the metrics that are associated
with that. And we're able to jump directly
from this particular service map
and look at the trace. We can see that, that availability
has dropped to 0. We've got high latency
on that link, basically 2 seconds,
and we can see the status code. This is
all, again, built into 1000 eyes. And
then from there, we basically open up the
trace. Within Splunk, we can show that
within Splunk and then move very, very quickly
towards a resolution. So now
we've seamlessly moved into Splunk.
We can basically see the traces here, OK?
And we can look at what's happening on
the, on the front end. And then in the API
list, we have 500 errors pretty much
all along the way.
We can then take that and then we can get
more information. We can actually look
at the stack trace, and we can identify
that there's an issue with the JSON code, you
know, within that trace. And then from that, we
can actually give that to our developers. They
can fix the issue
and move forward from there.
So again, this is really showing sort of a seamless
integration between all the
network telemetry, the 1000 eyes. Delivers
along with the visibility into applications and infrastructure
that Splunk delivers, all done in a very
seamless way. And the great thing about this is
you can take snapshots of these tests and,
and of these results and basically share them
with your stakeholders. You can share them with
third-party service providers or your cloud
providers as a way to sort of move towards,
again, a rapid and, and, and proactive
remediation.
OK, so what's next for you guys? Because my
talk is pretty much coming to a close now.
Um, even though I, I, I still do have some time
left. Um, but basically what we want you to
do, and, and I'm, by the way, I'm happy to take
questions from any of you afterwards. I'm gonna be
in the Splunk Cisco booth
right over there. I'm pointing at it.
Um, we have a demo pod over there. You can come and
I can show any of this to you there.
Happy to answer all your questions.
Happy to show you demos.
Um, but you can also, if you visit our booth,
if you attend one of our theater presentations there,
if you get some demos, we'll give you these really
cool collector pins. We've got some really cool
collector pins, I'll tell you.
And you get two of those, and you can take those up to
our desk and our, and our booth staff will basically give
you, um, a really cool,
um, and pithy sort of a t-shirt, kind
of like the one I'm wearing here.
The second thing you can do at our booth is basically talk
with an expert. So all the subject matter experts,
now, I'm actually with Cisco 1000
Eyes, so I can talk fairly intelligently
about 1000 Eyes, but I'm a lot less
intelligent when it comes to Splunk and all the
great things that they do.
So, but we have subject matter experts, not
only with Splunk 1 1000 Eyes, but we've got,
we've got experts in collaboration,
security, and all the other great things that Cisco
does across the board. Um, so we
really encourage you to visit our booth. And learn more
from our experts.
And then lastly,
uh, from 1000 eyes standpoint, we, we
do offer a free trial of our platform.
By default. It's a 15-day free trial,
but depending on the service that you're, that you're
actually, um, onboarding,
we can actually extend that as well. So,
sign up for a free trial. Just don't tell,
uh, the bean counters that, uh, that we're letting you do
that. So, uh, you know, you might get a,
we might get some nasty sort of stink eye looks
from, uh, from the accounting department.
Um, anyway, so I still have 5
minutes left,
um, but that's all for my presentation
today. I hope this has been informative on some level.
We're really looking towards,
you know, this new normal, right? Where, where,
the, the way that we used to operate, the
way that we used to manage, the tools that we used
to use are We're all basically going
away. We're moving towards a much more
AI driven, machine learning-driven, predictive
kind of an approach.
That's the goal here. And I hope that you are
all able to attain that and, uh,
and give your end users the higher, the highest
possible experiences that they can achieve.
So, thank you very much and hope to see you
over at the booth.